à la nage et anne restaurateur à paris
une étoile au guide michelin
bonjour alger m
merci de répondre à nos questions ce
matin tôt sur sur arte france
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes ce matin comment est ce que vous
êtes réveillé au lendemain de cette
décision du conseil constitutionnel qui
va donc vous obligé de lundi a exigé un
pass sanitaires à vos clients bah
écoutez ses combles de vue de chaque
fois il ne saura buffo loi on est un peu
perdu
je sois naître je souhaite adapter à
cette décision là mais à chaque fois
j'ai réfléchi profondément je vois
quelque chose qui sont très compliqués à
les gérer
qu'on a 1 terrasse de 60 m de personne
qui va prendre un café doit prendre un
perrier le cube à dîner et faire la
police c'est très compliqué mais c'est
vrai depuis l'année dernière en co
décision d'organisation on a fait
énormément des choses et là on en veut
juste ils savent tous que trouver la
solution pour se sortir on fait des
sorties de 7 c est ce qui est très
compliqué là on voit un peu le bout du
tunnel semble ouvert dans le même temps
dans la quiétude est on va refermer
maintenant le dise que l'appât sanitaire
c'est la seule solution pour vraiment
rester ouverts oui je l accepte et on
j'ai donné les consignes à mes équipes
de contrôle est vraiment les clients à
l'entrée des restaurants c'est tout
responsable vous allez faire pour
contrôler les clients à l'entrée de
votre restaurant est ce que vous allez
embaucher quelqu'un à plein temps déjà
déjà en fait dans la restauration je
peux vous dire depuis trois ou quatre
mois en galère à trouver des gens
vraiment cette galère totale maintenant
ont rembauché non mais est ce qu'on peut
faire le travail à 100% je peux vous
dire aussi non on va essayer à faire
notre maximum depuis le début on a
montré qu'on ait beaucoup destinée on a
accepté beaucoup les règles et on a
impliqué beaucoup les règles mais là
aujourd'hui on bien sûr y aura quelques
restaurants comme la nôtre renommée aux
étoiles et il ya une autorité combat
contre les tous mais aujourd'hui je à
mon avis c'est une mission qui est
impossible
quinze mille restaurant à la capitale
17000 restaurant il ya des quartiers
différents quais aux autres pour
contrôler tellement
c'est impossible déjà pendant la
fermeture y arriver sans terre des
restos plans distincts pour imaginer
maintenant pour un petit clic sur un
passé militaire mais envoie le faire le
travail
aujourd'hui la différence entre les gens
qui sont contre avec moi je me permets
pas maintenant on se fait dire oui je
suis contre et avec parce que j'ai un
restaurant j'ai entreprise il faut que
je le protège
il faut qu'elle survit cette
entreprise-là déjà depuis des immenses
et notre travail quotidien de ceux de
protéger cette entreprise à le sauver et
là maintenant et vous faire confiance à
l'état depuis des humains le suivant le
sens le suit l'état parce que dans notre
tête que la fin du tunnel on va trouver
une solution
on va sortir de cette crise dans cette
rue c'est notre seul choix en fait on
n'a pas d'autre choix donc vous acceptez
bon an mal an c'est cette nouvelle
mesure mais est ce que vous craignez une
perte de votre chiffre d'affaires
absolument bien sûr il y aura le garder
aujourd'hui il ya combien pourcentage
des gens vaccinés en france il ya 60%
geos nous sommes chaque jour
by aura 60% de l'activité dans un
restant ça va être l'impact à quotidien
parce qu'aujourd'hui la table de
familles qui sont de vacciner le toulois
pas vaccinés ils vont 10 banon
finalement on va pas le rester on va
manger à la maison on va retomber dans
la même truc peut-être la vente à
importer ça va reprendre parce que ça
endormi un peu mais là on est beaucoup
crient crack en fait c'est impérieux
très compliqué sa période de survivre
c'est un période
il faut faire le dos rond des attendent
être très patient je sais c'est très
difficile parce que ça fait des yeux
manque en galère mais à chaque fois
change l'histoire - est toujours dans la
même main de on sait pas on y va et
toujours de l'inquiétude que les jours
je regarde le taux de deux hôpitaux le
patient ça a augmenté ou pas il ya
toujours oui est-ce qu'on va refermer à
ce qu un quatrième vague
maintenant c'est très compliqué en fait
très compliqué mais moi j'ai quatre
restaurants ccc mais ça fait 25 ans je
travaille pour lui les avoir c'est le
seul moyen d aujourd'hui accepter ces
décisions-là respecter les règles et en
espérant que dans quelques mois ce sera
vraiment de passer
vous êtes étoilé comment réagissent vos
confrères de la restauration gastronomie
canadian
on a beaucoup entendu durant la crise
sanitaire les têtes d'affiché un
philippe etchebest michel sarran monté
au créneau cette fois comment vont
réagir les meilleurs chefs de france est
ce qu'une action en commun est elle
envisageable par exemple annoncé c'est
très compliqué en fait c'est quelque
chose on ne peut pas le maîtriser mais
on va essayer tout pour le faire parce
que c'est le décision c'était ça quand
j'ai dit le début on est beaucoup
dessiner c'est une révolte ou le monde
contre tout le monde aujourd'hui si vous
êtes mon avis à l'intérieur j'ai dit si
c'est n'importe quoi mais aujourd'hui
voilà chez un chef d'entreprise là j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai un exemple de règles et
décision il faut qu'on montre qu' on va
respecter ces décisions là on peut
parler s'il avait parlé avec vos clients
avant évidemment que le conseil
constitutionnel ne donne son feu vert
hier
comment réagissent vos clients d'une
manière générale vous savez aujourd'hui
les le plupart des français c'est des
gens qui sont très disciplinés
le plupart des gens m'aiment pas cette
semaine commençait à venir en disant oui
nous sommes à vacciner vos actes et pas
à vacciner vacciner ce à commencer par
faire la bise à des amis ou des clients
des habitués à on est vacciné vous
inquiétez pas demain il y aura quelques
problèmes sanitaires on peut quand même
attrapé le kobe de 19 même si on est
vaccinés ah oui tout à fait tout à fait
mais après aujourd'hui il ya des gens
qui restent avec moi on peut dire 90%
c'est que ces règles est là mais
toujours un grand en majorité qui vont
aller dans la rue faire la fête c'est
faire la bise et tout ça c'est c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est des
règles depuis deux ans que les gens
qu'ils en font mais l'âme et on est un
peu marre on a envie retourne à la vie
normale et nous les dans le milieu quand
je vous dis j'ai un restaurant
aujourd'hui descendre dans la rue ont
manifesté au parler pendant deux mois je
n'accepte pas d'être vacciné aulas pas
salutaire pour au moins ils fichiers
dans l'urgence il faut que je réagis
rapidement il faut que mon restants et
continuer à survivre il faut que je
garde mes salariés c'est simple et
compliqué merci à la jam d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes restaurateur à paris
vous avez notamment une étoile au guide
michelin